so i'm fascinated about learning like
the behind the scenes of the making of a
movie
uh what do you think might surprise
people to learn about the making of a
marvel movie like black widow
well the thing that most surprised me
was that
uh this is obviously a huge
corporation marvel and the
budgets are huge and the sets are huge
um but the actual experience for
just an actor like myself um
was incredibly intimate um
and felt more like
an independent movie in terms of the
performance aspect of things the
executives from marvel all the producers
they're very
protective of the actors imagination and
they ask you
if you'd like to contribute and your
ideas end up in the script and
um they're very nurturing and and it's
very um
kind of like being with a really nice
family yeah
this could explain how they managed to
get such great actors to be in all their
movies
i'm sure i'm sure yeah it was it was
very surprising
it was not very very warm experience
what's it been like for you for the last
few years talking about this movie
without saying
anything well i haven't really
talked about it very much to anyone
we've just started doing press now but
um i know what you mean yeah i just uh
rather like molina i have to keep a very
straight face and betray
nothing oh i'm curious when you signed
on for the
for joining the mcu do they take you
aside and say
we have a plan for you know multi like
you know you might be around for a
number of movies or like how much are
you talking about
like a long-term plan and how much is it
like just this project
i mean it would be different for every
actor but
for me it was just just for this film
[Music]
got it
um i am curious uh one of the things
about this film that i think that people
might not expect is it's actually really
funny
i genuinely laughed out loud watching it
even with all the seriousness of the
film
what was your reaction watching the
finished uh film
i agree i think it's got some killer
funny lines and moments
um you know and for me the reason why
it's so funny is because the actors are
so committed
they're not you know playing for laughs
they're they're
yeah that's why will farrell
so funny right because he's just so
serious about what he's saying
so yeah i found it very funny uh i'm
curious are you still playing elizabeth
taylor
in that film a special relationship yes
when when are you actually coming
together soon
um i hope so everything has gotten
delayed
obviously it was meant to be making it
over a year ago but
um uh hopefully next year
got it and also i'm excited for you
partnering up again with colin
in todd's film love child um so
is that going soon as well or um we
don't have any
dates it won't be this year but
hopefully next year as well
uh i already have to stop i'm just gonna
say seriously great work in this film
hope it's a huge hit thank you thank you
so much